Well,
hello, how are you? Sali Jaramillo greets you
with his brief information for today, Monday
, August 9, it is the first day of classes
for the students of
the Clark County School District, as a new
measure, all minors must wear
masks inside the
establishments, as well as the
workforce approximately 310
thousand students will attend classrooms
today after more than a year of pandemic
and with the return to class we
remind drivers that they must drive
carefully in school zones since
thousands of students will be walking
to schools  in the morning pay
attention to the road and don't turn or
look at your phone
some changes in
grades for this school year the
district mandated the lowest
grade 50% factors such as behavior
attendance participation or not turning
in assignments  they will not impact the final note
in tribute to the people of the
late mica mail bitcoin and the
patrol  of roads and highways come together
to organize a blood donation event
this Wednesday this will be inside
the building of the department of
public safety on sánchez from 10 in
the morning to 5 in the afternoon for more
information you can visit our
page at disney.com la  section in
spanish and now we go to
the weather forecast we will have a sunny day with
temperatures reaching 107 degrees
for today we will continue with this heat for
the rest of the week as well as a 10%
chance of rain on tuesday beautiful
day I am salí jaramillo and  this was his
brief informative for them in Spanish
[Music]